لم تعد غزه ماساه فلسطينيه بل صارت ماساه
انسانيه تمسك برقبه العالم وتسائل بقسوه
عن اخلاقه وقيمه
وانسانيته غزه مراه ربما يرى فيها العالم
الغربي لا سيما ذلك الزاعم لنفسه رياده
حضاريه بشاعه صورته اذ يستعيد ماضيه الذي
احيته المجازر في غزه على يد
الاسرائيليين فكانها بعث بماساه المجتمعات
الامنه التي اغرقها الغزاه الاستعماريون
في دمائها ابان الحقبه الاستعماريه وستغدو
عباره من حق اسرائيل الدفاع عن نفسها
ترجمه عمليه لمبدا استعماري غربي هو من حق
الغزاه حمايه لانفسهم قتل السكان
الاصليين اسرائيل فعلت ما فعل الغرب تماما
من قبل وهو القتل عوضا عن حمايه المغتصبه
ارضهم فالاس لي يصدر عن ذات المورد الغربي
المتماهي معه يرى فيه صورته المستبده
بالقوه الممجد لها كل روح لطفل او لامراه
او لشيخ تزهق بسبب القصف لاله الحرب
الاسرائيليه تمثل فتحا لدمو الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
على منطق من حق اسرائيل الدفاع عن نفسها
فالحرب تكشف لا اخلاقيه هذه العباره
المشرعن للقتل الى تلك الدرجه التي تجعل
من الحاله
الصهيونيه خارج السويه الانسانيه واذا بدا
ثمه تماه بين اسرائيل وبين الغرب في
انعدام الحساسيه الاخلاقيه تجاه القتل
فلان التجربه الصهيونيه نشات في كنف
التجربه الاستعماريه الغربيه فكما تقتل
اسرائيل اليوم شعبا في جريمه ترقى الى
مستوى ابادته وتهجيره عن ارضه فان التجربه
الاستعماريه الغربيه من بريطانيا الى
فرنسا الى ايطاليا فضلا عن التجربه
الاستعماريه الامريكيه كلها كانت مؤسسه
على القتل واباده السكان الاصليين قرابين
للامجاد
الامبراطوريه او اخضاعهم بالقوه يصنعون
بموارده وعرقهم فراديس تخفي وراء جمالها
جماجم الضحايا هذه الصوره هي مما يتبرا
منها الالاف المؤلفه في الشوارع الاوروبيه
الذين خرجوا مطالبين بوقف الحرب ومستنكرين
انحياز دولهم الى
اسرائيل مجازر غزه وعنفها وسفك دم
الابرياء فيها فصل يستقر غير قلق في كتاب
العنف الغربي ضد الشعوب الاخرى وهي ما
يجعل حاله الانحياز لاسرائيل
سلوكا طبيعيا ينسجم مع التاريخ الدموي
لهذه الامم حرب غزه ليست شاهده على فشل
الغرب في وقف اباده جماعيه لشعب تحت
الاحتلال تبث على العالم صباحا ومساء بل
هي فطح لانحيازه الدول الغربيه لاسرائيل
وهي كشف عن عدم الاتساق الاخلاقي وخذلان
لقيم ما اكثر ما ادعاها الغرب لنفسه وما
اكثر ما وبخ الاخرين على خرقها حرب غزه
اسقطت كل المزاعم انها وثيقه مصوره لجرائم
قتل تشكل ادانه لكل دول العالم فكيف يراها
احرار العالم انها ادانه لمفهوم المجتمع
الدولي ادانه للمنظومه الحقوقيه الدوليه
ادانه لمفهوم العالم الحر ولمز التحدر
ادانه للاعلان العالمي لحقوق
الانسان وادانه للقوميه العربيه الطل الذي
نشات عليه القطريه المكفي على احلامها
الصغيره ادانه للعالم الاسلامي الذي لم
ينصر غزه كما نصر الامريكيون والغرب
اسرائيل بداعيه ان اسرائيل تشبهنا وهي منا
في هذا العالم الذي يتداعى يوشك ان يسقط
لا تشده الى انسانيته قوه من حق والذي
تداس فيه قيم وكل مواريث الكرامه
الانسانيه ينهي قاده العرب والعالم
الاسلامي قمه لهم حول غزه وقد اشتمل
بيانها الختامي على احدى و3 مساله كلها
تدعم غزه بانكار وشجب ما ترتكبه اسرائيل
من جرائم ومجازر لاهل القطاع وتتوافق على
الدعم المالي والدبلوماسي
للفلسطينيين وترفض تهجيرهم وتعمل على
تمكينهم من اقامه دولتهم وفق الشرعيه
الدوليه ومبادر السلام عربيه لكن السؤال
المعجزه هو من يوقف الحرب ومن سيكسر
الحصار عن قطاع غزه
من